Old MacDonald had a farm, E - I - E - I - O.
And on his farm he had some chicks, E - I - E - I - O.
With a chick chick here and a chick chick there.
Here a chick, there a chick, everywhere a chick chick.
Old MacDonald had a farm, E - I - E - I - O.
And on his farm he had a cow, E - I - E - I - O.
With a moo moo here and a moo moo there.
Here a moo, there a moo, everywhere a moo moo.
Chick chick here, and a chick chick there.
Here a chick, there a chick, everywhere a chick chick.
Old MacDonald had a farm, E - I - E - I - O.
And on his farm he had some ducks, E - I - E - I - O.
With a quack quack here and a quack quack there.
Here a quack, there a quack, everywhere a quack quack.
Moo moo here and a moo moo there.
Here a moo, there a moo, everywhere a moo moo.
Chick chick here and a chick chick there.
Here a chick, there a chick, everywhere a chick chick.
Old MacDonald had a farm, E - I - E - I - O.